está con nosotros eduardo biscayart
periodista deportivo de telemundo y
experto en atletismo eduardo bienvenido
y muchas gracias por acompañarnos para
hacer este balance
y cómo te va a amar un placer
eduardo que nos dice en estas primeras
competencias internacionales de cara a
lo que puede ser el mundial de oregón
bueno yo creo que marcan un poco la
tendencia y la temporada esta es una
temporada larga está recién comenzando
pero estamos viendo ciertas plantas que
están muy bien a shelly ann fraser pryce
está muy bien
allison
brendon alves dos santos el brasileño
que también está muy bien está tratando
de reclamar ante ciertas situaciones que
se han dado como lesiones y bajas de
otros atletas
probablemente el lugar más alto en el
podio entonces la temporada se va
perfilando esta temporada muy particular
porque en la próxima temporada
volveremos a tener campeonato del mundo
y también para nuestra región vamos a
tener los juegos panamericanos por lo
tanto
creo que hay gente que todavía no ha
mostrado todavía sus mejores cartas
este
hemos visto caer varios de los
favoritismos más sólidos caer o
tambalearse al menos varios de los
favoritismos más sólidos del atletismo
estamos hablando por ejemplo la derrota
de ryan braun sólo en el mundial bajo
techo antes de darla en romaní es
digamos esta temporada tambaleante la
perspectiva de que cars en warhole ni
siquiera esté a punto para defender el
título de los 400 con vallas en el
mundial que tanto pueden seguir
usufructuando o aprovechando estos
tambaleos los atletas atletas como
romaní o como el brasileño ali son dos
santos y sólo por citar dos
latinoamericanos que han tenido buenas
temporadas
pero yo creo que allison ha comenzado
muy bien la temporada
e incluso ha hecho su mejor marca en 400
metros planos esta creo que imbatido en
400 metros con vallas y eso me parece
que le da una seguridad aparte de que se
mantenga todavía joven en un punto de
evolución más allá del tiempo
extraordinario que vino de parte de
warhol en los juegos olímpicos de tokio
que no sé si será alcanzable por él yo
creo que es bastante tangible la
posibilidad de que él sea campeón del
mundo en el caso de román y yo creo que
román hizo un pico muy importante en el
mundial bajo techo de belgrado y que
ahora vamos a ver si lo puede rectificar
el tema es que para él sería muy
importante conseguir ese doblete mundial
bajo techo mundial al aire libre y bueno
esta es una cita también muy particular
porque me sabe muy bien aún márquez los
mundiales se solían hacer en años
impares y ahora lo estamos haciendo un
año para por todas las situaciones que
hemos venido arrastrando de la pandemia
y eso también me parece que ha
modificado mucho los calendarios de
preparación de los atletas de hecho yo
lima roja por ejemplo la venezolana
tenía que estrenar en la temporada del
fin de semana pasado en madrid y tuvo
problemas físicos la plusmarquista del
mundo campeona olímpica campeona del
mundo y lamentablemente no pudo arrancar
en un torneo que hay
hablábamos del caso de los cubanos díaz
ha perdido una importante cantidad de
figuras cuba que es uno de los grandes
protagonistas latinoamericanos en los
campeonatos del mundo y hemos visto la
insurgencia o el surgimiento de una
república dominicana que en velocidad
está marcando pauta con atletas como
mari lady paulino como
incluso cofidis que quedó en cuarto
lugar este este fin de semana en parís
que tanto puede consolidarse a lo que
hemos visto hasta el momento de esa
actuación dominicana pueden ser
protagonistas aparte de paulino en el
mundial
bueno vamos por dominicanas creo que
marc y ladies y más allá de que minero
vivo este de semana ganó en parís ella
dice que hizo una especie de test de 300
metros y que después se estiró para el
400 pero ver como dejando ir las piernas
paulino con su victoria en el campeonato
iberoamericano en la nucía en alicante
en españa tiene la mejor marca mundial
de la temporada entonces ella hoy por
hoy podría llegar a ser considerada
favorita en cuanto por ejemplo antonio
zambrano ha comenzado la temporada y no
había comenzado del todo bien porque va
lentamente tendrá los juegos
bolivarianos y me parece que ese es el
objetivo para la primera parte de la
temporada entonces hay gente que me
parece y ha mencionado así el caso de
los triplistas cubanos muchos de ellos
no pueden en jordan días no puede
representar ya a cuba porque ya tienen
la nacionalidad española pero no tiene
todavía la posibilidad de representar
internacionalmente a cuba ha vivido en
los últimos tiempos y más aún en los
últimos dos años una salida realmente
seria talento que en algún momento no sé
suponemos que hará replantearse ciertas
cosas como ya ha pasado con otros
deportes para evitar que la gente de
pista y campo no siga abandonando al
arte tipo cubano eduardo le agradecemos
mucho haber estado con nosotros
gracias
brass